[Music]  we say I want you to be my VP I want you  you my vice  well George honey I'm the CEO of a large  company and I have been Secretary of  Defense and I have been White House  chief of staff the vice presidency is a  mostly symbolic job however if we came  to a different understanding I can  handle the more mundane jobs but we're  seeing bureaucracy military energy  and foreign policy yeah right I like  that  [Music]  when you have power people will always  try to take it from you always  are you even more ruthless than you used  to be  first  so we're gonna do the Stan whatever is  this happening I believe we can make  this work damn  [Music]